INVESTIGATION INTO THE JANUARY
6th CAPITOL RIOTS, AND THE
BATTLE OVER TESTIMONY AND
DOCUMENTS.
A FEW MINUTES AGO, PRESIDENT
BIDEN REFUSED TO ASSERT
PRIVILEGE OVER TRUMP ERA
DOCUMENTS.
THESE ARE THE ONES SOUGHT BY THE
HOUSE SELECT COMMITTEE LOOKING
INTO THE INSURRECTION THAT PAVES
THE WAY FOR THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES TO SHARE DOCUMENTS WITH
THE HOUSE PROBE.
ALSO TODAY, A LAWYER FOR TRUMP
ASSOCIATE STEVE BANNON INFORMED
THE SELECT COMMITTEE THAT HE
WILL NOT COOPERATE WITH THE
SUBPOENA.
A SHORT TIME AGO, THE COMMITTEE
RESPONDED, THREATENING A
CRIMINAL REFERRAL FOR ANY
WITNESS WHO CONTINUES TO
OBSTRUCT.
TRUMP'S LEGAL TEAM SET OFF THIS
BATTLE EARLIER THIS WEEK,
TELLING BANNON AND THREE OTHERS,
THREE OF THE KEY ALLIES THAT
THEY SHOULD NOT COMPLY WITH THE
SUBPOENAS.
CNN'S KAITLAN COLLINS IS LIVE AT
THE WHITE HOUSE, AND CNN'S SARA
MURRAY IS IN WASHINGTON AS WELL.
K
TELL US FIRST ABOUT THE DECISION
BY THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION NOT
TO ASSERT EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE
HERE.
>> YEAH, THEY SAY THIS IS AN
EXTRAORDINARY SET OF
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT HAS LED THEM
TO MAKE THIS DECISION C.
THEY HAVE SENT THIS LETTER
SAYING THEY ARE NOT GOING TO
EXERT EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE OVER
THESE DOCUMENTS.
ONE THING WE SHOULD BE CLEAR
HERE, THEY ARE SAYING THIS IS
ABOUT THE SPECIFIC REQUEST OF
DOCUMENTS, THE WHITE HOUSE AND
THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES HAS
RECEIVED FROM THE XCOMMITTEE,
WHICH HAS BEEN OF COURSE A
MASSIVE QUESTION AT THE HEART OF
ALL OF THIS GIVEN TO ESSENTIALLY
WHAT IT WAS THAT FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP KNEW AND WAS
DOING AND WAS SAYING ON THAT
DAY.
BUT NOW PRESS SECRETARY JEN
PSAKI CONFIRMING THAT PRESIDENT
BIDEN HAS MADE THIS DECISION.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS DETERMINED
THAT AN ASSERTION OF EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE IS NOT WARRANTED FOR
THE FIRST SET OF DOCUMENTS FROM
THE TRUMP WHITE HOUSE THAT HAVE
BEEN PROVIDED TO US BY THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES.
WE WILL EVALUATE QUESTIONS OF
PRIVILEGE ON A CASE BY CASE
BASIS BUT THE PRESIDENT HAS ALSO
BEEN CLEAR THAT HE BELIEVES IT
TO BE OF THE UTMOST IMPORTANCE
OF CONGRESS AND THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE TO HAVE A COMPLETE
UNDERSTANDING OF THE EVENTS OF
THAT DAY TO PREVENT THEM FROM
HAPPENING AGAIN.
>> SO MAKING CLEAR AGAIN THAT
THIS IS ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS.
WE SHOULD NOTE THIS INITIAL SET
IS A REQUEST OF DOCUMENTS FROM
THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE IS
PRETTY BIG, AND IT TALKS ABOUT
HOW THEY WANT THINGS FROM
CALENDARS, SCHEDULED, LOGS OF
MOVEMENTS, BY FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP ON THAT DAY.
THEY WANT COMMUNICATIONS THAT
HAPPENED WITHIN THE WHITE HOUSE
RELATED TO THAT RALLY, OF
COURSE, THAT HAPPENED BEFORE THE
RIOTS ON CAPITOL HILL.
THE ONE THAT HAPPENED OVER HERE
ON THE NATIONAL MALL, AND WHEN
YOU LOOK AT IN REQUEST, THEY SAY
THEY WANT DOCUMENTS AND
COMMUNICATIONS WITHIN THE WHITE
HOUSE ON JANUARY 6th RELATED TO
HOPE HICKS, SARAH MATTHEWS WHO
WAS AN ASSISTANT PRESS AIDE,
MARK MEADOWS, OF COURSE THE
CHIEF OF STAFF, DAN SCAVINO, THE
PRESIDENT'S TOP AIDE.
PAT CIPOLLONE, THE WHITE HOUSE
COUNSEL, MARK SHORT, FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT PENCE'S CHIEF OF
STAFF, SEVERAL OF THE HIGHEST OF
HIGHEST OFFICIALS IN THE WHITE
HOUSE ON THAT DAY, THAT IS WHAT
THESE DOCUMENTS RELATE TO, AND
NOW THE WHITE HOUSE IS SAYING
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO EXERT
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE OVER THOSE
DOCUMENTS.
>> OVER TO YOU ON THE SUBPOENAS,
AND THE LETTER FROM THE
COMMITTEE, THEIR RESPONSE.
WALK US THROUGH WHAT WE'RE
LEARNING THROUGH THAT LETTER,
AND WHAT THE CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR ARE SAYING.
>> YESTERDAY WAS THE DEADLINE
FOR A HANDFUL OF THESE TRUMP
LOYALISTS TO HAND OVER
DOCUMENTS, FOLKS INCLUDING MARK
MEADOWS, DAN SCAVINO, STEVE
BANNON, AND IT BECAME VERY CLEAR
THAT STEVE BANNON WAS NOT
PLANNING TO COMPLY EITHER WITH A
REQUEST FOR DOCUMENTS OR
TESTIMONY, HERE'S A PORTION OF
THE LAWYER THAT HIS ATTORNEY
SENT YESTERDAY.
IT SAYS THE KEXECUTIVE PRIVILEGS
BELONG WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP, WE
MUST HONOR HIS EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE.
STEVE BANNON, THOUGH HE WASN'T
WORKING AT THE WHITE HOUSE IN
THE JANUARY 6th INSURRECTION IS
STILL TRYING TO HIDE BEHIND THE
PRIVILEGE CLAIM.
THEY MAY NOT HOLD UP WHEN TESTED
IN COURT, THE COMMITTEE SAID
THEY'VE HAD SOME ENGAGEMENT WITH
CASH PATEL, SOME ENGAGEMENT WITH
MARK MEADOWS, OBVIOUSLY GETTING
STONE WALLED BY STEVE BANNON, WE
WILL NOT ALLOW A WITNESS TO DEFY
A LAWFUL SUBPOENA OR ATTEMPT TO
ROLL OUT THE CLOCK, AND WILL
SWIFTLY ADVANCE A CRIMINAL
CONTEMPT OF CONGRESS REFERRAL.
THE ONE THING WE SHOULD NOTE IS
SUBPOENA FIGHTS DO TAKE TIME.
IT'S UNCLEAR HOW MUCH TIME THEY
COULD TAKE.
IT'S NOT LIKE THIS IS A
COMMITTEE THAT HAS YEARS AND
YEARS TO LET THESE FIGHTS
LANGUISH.
IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE
HOW THIS PROCEEDS.
>> SARA MURRAY.
KAITLAN COLLINS, THANK YOU BOTH.
LET'S DISCUSS WITH CNN POLITICAL
ANA
ANALYST GLORIA BORGER, AND CNN
ANALYST.
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE QUESTIONS
AND THE TDOCUMENTS AND RECORDS
REQUESTED THUS FAR, THAT'S NOT A
BLANKET RESPONSE.
AT SOME POINT IT'S POSSIBLE THAT
THEY COULD.
>> OF COURSE, AND THAT'S THE WAY
PRIVILEGE WORKS.
YOU KNOW, IT WOULD NEVER APPLY
TO A WHOLE CLASS OF DOCUMENTS OR
EVERY WORD THAT CAME OUT OF
SOMEONE'S MOUTH.
WHAT LAWYERS FOR THE PARTIES,
YOU KNOW, THE FORMER PRESIDENT
AND THE CURRENT PRESIDENT WOULD
DO IS GO THROUGH EACH DOCUMENT,
ALL OF THE MATERIALS, AND
IDENTIFY WHAT WOULD BE SUBJECT
TO PRIVILEGE.
IF THEY WERE ASSERTING IT, IT
WOULDN'T BE THE CASE THAT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WOULD SAY,
YOU KNOW, EVERY SINGLE WORD THAT
CAME OUT OF DONALD TRUMP'S MOUTH
THE ENTIRE TIME HE WAS PRESIDENT
IS SUBJECT TO DISCLOSURE.
WHAT THEY HAVE DONE HERE IS FOR
THIS TRANCHE OF DOCUMENTS, THOSE
ARE NOT GOING TO BE PROTECTED BY
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
AND THEY WON'T ASSERT ANY.
>> TO YOU GLORIA, PART OF THE
STATEMENT FROM THE COMMITTEE,
BENNIE THOMPSON, LIZ CHENEY VICE
CHAIR, THEY WRITE THAT WE WILL
NOT ALLOW ANY WITNESS TO DEFY A
LAWFUL SUBPOENA OR ATTEMPT TO
RUN OUT THE CLOCK.
THAT CERTAINLY IS WHAT THE PLAY
BOOK HAS BEEN FOR THE FORMER
PRESIDENT AND HIS ALLIES UP TO
THIS POINT.
THE QUESTION IS WILL THE DOJ,
AND I'LL PUT THIS TO ELLIOT
AFTERWARD, THEN FOLLOW UP WITH
THIS CRIMINAL REFERRAL.
>> IT'S FUNNY BECAUSE ELLIOT AND
I WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT THAT
BEFORE WE CAME ON THE AIR, AND
HE'S THE LAWYER, SO I WILL DEFER
TO HIM.
BUT IT SEEMS TO ME, AS YOU'RE
POINTING OUT, TIME IS OF THE
ESSENCE.
IF YOU'RE THE COMMITTEE, YOU
DON'T WANT TO LET WITNESSES RUN
OUT THE CLOCK.
YOU COULD HAVE A CRIMINAL
CONTEMPT REFERRAL TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
THAT CAN TAKE AN AWFULLY LONG
TIME OR YOU COULD GO THE CIVIL
CONTEMPT ROUTE, AND GIVE IT TO A
JUDGE OR YOU COULD TRY AND DO
BOTH AND SEE WHICH WORKS FASTER.
YOU KNOW, THERE'S NO GUARANTEE
THAT IF THEY SENT THIS OVER TO
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT THAT THE
NEW ATTORNEY GENERAL WOULD SAY,
SURE, GO RIGHT AHEAD.
THERE REALLY ISN'T.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY'RE GOING
TO DECIDE.
I THINK THEY HAVE OPTIONS, AND
I'LL LET ELLIOT TELL THE REST OF
THAT STORY.
>> ABOUT THAT, I MEAN, WHAT IS
THE STANDARD, THEN, FOR IF THEY
WERE TO GET THAT REFERRAL TO
MAKE THE CASE THAT IT REACHES A
CRIME.
>> AGAIN, THERE'S TWO VERY
DIFFERENT THINGS.
ONE, A CRIMINAL REFERRAL, YOU'RE
JUST SEEKING TO PUNISH A PERSON
FOR NOT COMPLYING WITH THE
INVESTIGATION, AND FRANKLY, EVEN
IF YOU PUNISH THEM, YOU DON'T
GET THE TESTIMONY, YOU'RE
BASICALLY SLAPPING THEM ON THE
WRIST WITH A MISDEMEANOR PUTTING
THEM IN JAIL, OF COURSE, BUT
YOU'RE NOT GETTING CLOSER TO
GETTING THE TESTIMONY.
YOU COULD SUE IN CIVIL COURT TO
ENFORCE THE SUBPOENA, AND IN ALL
LIKELIHOOD, I WOULD THINK WHAT
CONGRESS COULD DO IS JUST DO
BOTH AT THE SAME TIME.
MEANWHILE, THEY'RE ALSO STILL
CONDUCTING THEIR INVESTIGATION
WHICH IS MOVING AT A BREAKNECK
PACE, YOU KNOW, NEXT WEEK
THEY'VE GOT MORE DOCUMENTS
COMING IN AND PRESUMABLY MORE
TESTIMONY, SO, YOU KNOW, THEY
HAVE A BUNCH OF TOOLS, AND THEY
ISSUE THAT STATEMENT, THEY
HEDGED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
WHETHER THEY WOULD DEFINITELY DO
IT.
BUT THEY CAN EASILY GO DOWN THE
ROAD OF BOTH SIMULTANEOUSLY, AND
THEY HAVE BEEN TESTED IN THE
COURTS BEFORE.
THERE'S A BASIS FOR IT.
YEAH.
>> YOU KNOW, REMEMBER, THIS IS A
CONGRESS THAT HAS BEEN -- THIS
HAS BEEN A PROBLEM FOR YEARS
WITH THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION,
NOW THE WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE PART
OF THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, AND
SO THEY HAVE BEEN THINKING ABOUT
THIS FOR A LONG TIME, AND THEY
ARE CLEARLY UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
GOING ON THEORY, AND WANT TO GET
THIS DONE.
THEY HAVE A CLOCK.
THE CLOCK IS YOU HAVE THE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS COMING UP,
OBVIOUSLY.
THEY WANT TO GET TO THE BOTTOM
OF THIS.
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER THEY'RE
INTERESTED IN CRIMINAL REFERRALS
FOR PEOPLE.
I THINK WHAT THEY'RE INTERESTED
IN IS FINDING OUT THE TRUTH
ABOUT WHO KNEW WHAT WHEN,
PARTICULARLY THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES, ON JANUARY
5th, ON JANUARY 6th, AND I THINK
THAT'S THEIR GOAL, AND THE
FASTEST WAY THEY CAN GET THERE
IS PROBABLY WHAT THEY'RE GOING
TO DO.
BECAUSE REMEMBER, DON MCGHAN,
THE FORMER WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL
TOOK AN AWFULLY LONG TIME TO GET
HIM TO TESTIFY, SO THEY DON'T
WANT TO GO THROUGH THAT AGAIN.
THEY HAVE BEEN THINKING ABOUT
THIS.
>> YEAH, OF COURSE THE POINT OF
ALL OF THIS, AS YOU POINT OUT,
GLORIA, ALTHOUGH WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE LEGAL AVENUES AND
OPPORTUNITIES AND AVENUES FOR
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IS WHO WAS
INVOLVED WITH THE PLANNING OF
THE JANUARY 6th PROTEST THAT
TURNED INTO AN INSURRECTION, WHO
IS RESPONSIBLE.
ELLIOT, LET ME COME BACK TO YOU
ON THE AG.
WE'VE NOW GOT THIS REPORT FROM
THE SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
THAT SHOWS THERE WAS THIS
PRESSURE ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO OVERTURN THE
ELECTION.
WHAT CAN, ON THAT SPECIFICALLY,
ATTORNEY GENERAL GARLAND DO IF
THE SELECT COMMITTEE DOESN'T GET
SOMETHING DONE?
>> RIGHT.
WELL, WHAT'S MORE IMPORTANT, IN
THAT REPORT, THEY SAY THAT IT'S
NOT JUST ATTORNEY GENERAL
GARLAND.
IT'S ALSO CONGRESS.
THERE'S A FEW THINGS THAT CAN
HAPPEN NOW.
NUMBER ONE, CONGRESS CAN TIGHTEN
THE RULES ON THE TYPE OF
COMMUNICATIONS THAT CAN HAPPEN
WITHIN THE WHITE HOUSE, AND
BETWEEN THE WHITE HOUSE AND THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT CAN ALSO
CLARIFY ITS RULES WITH RESPECT
TO COMMUNICATIONS IN THE LEAD UP
TO AN ELECTION.
LOOKS, IT'S EGREGIOUS CONDUCT
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT A WHITE HOUSE
COMMUNICATING WITH THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT ON ANY OCCASION, LET
ALONE NINE TIMES IN THE RUN UP
TO OR IMMEDIATELY AFTER AN
ELECTION.
SO THEY HAVE THINGS THEY CAN DO.
I'M QUITE FRANKLY, QUITE
THRILLED THAT CONGRESS
RECOMMENDED THINGS AND STEPS TO
BE TAKEN RATHER THAN SIMPLY
SAYING OH, THIS IS SO EGREGIOUS
AND WE HOPE IT NEVER HAPPENS
AGAIN.
THEY FLOATED THE PROSPECT OF BAR
SANCTIONS AGAINST JEFFREY CLARK
WHICH WAS ITSELF SIGNIFICANT, SO
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT WHEN
CONGRESS ACTUALLY DOES SOMETHING
OR RECOMMENDS SOMETHING, RATHER
THAN JUST COMPLAINS, AND THEY
HAVE DONE THAT IN JUST THIS
REPORT, WHICH IS ONLY INTERIM.
THERE'S ANOTHER ONE AFTER THIS
THAT'S GOING TO LAY OUT EVEN
MORE OF THE MISCONDUCT, I THINK.
>> WE SAW THE REBUTTAL FROM THE
REPUBLICANS OUT OF SENATOR
GRASSLEY'S OFFICE SAYS T